hey guys how's it go and so today we are
here at book on and we're doing a panel
and we're doing a signing and I'm so
excited because your strata Shane and
Shana your ideas fun ok all right this
moment I do feel scared me no frightened
oh my god i just take oh my god are you
doing we're behind the scenes here we're
about to go out we've gone up so we've
got Connor Shane we've got Joey
and communication
so we did our panel and I just actually
introduced you to blow on stage and I'm
sort of overwhelmed does that actually
happen but it really did oh but yeah
Joey you're leaving me not you going on
tour so were you in Chicago and then
we're Bora taxes Boston you can golly
you got you got a quick tour so guys she
will see Joey and I'm sorry I'm not
bringing it was recently I had one job
it was to bring you to Pittsburgh maybe
I'll do it all stop okay but probably
i'll bring in one day I'll put it in my
series literally like this is my camera
watch watch yeah we'd you bet in LA oh
yes you know well now they're pissed off
because you could have taken me to
Pittsburgh but you decided to make it
hello getting he'll be indifferent I
want to take a rough
my name's Kat and hacked the dress with
all of our faces on it look at this this
is so fantastic Oh miss and Connor oh my
gosh back on earth
she didn't forget about you that's
amazing i love it it's so much one of
the meat of it was so amazing meeting
all of you guys and thank you for all a
little present um this is pretty awesome
these are some candles and i love that
it says I hope this warms up at least 12
of your days 12 very specific amount of
ways have some t-shirts and some camo oh
my goodness holy moly you guys are the
best red nose knowledge its vast wise so
this is the day a wrap up before I go to
bed I'm so excited today was so amazing
i got to meet so many of you guys and I
bout lost my mind not only do I get to
meet you guys but I met Judy Blume and I
met RL stine and it was just such an
amazing book on and now I'm off to my
next destination which is actually here
in New York so my book officially comes
out on jun second and i'll be doing my
launch at the barnes and noble and
Tribeca and that's on the second and
then the third I'll be in New Jersey so
I'm looking forward to seeing all of you
guys there check out the facebook events
link below and you could find out where
else you could meet me on this tour I
can't wait to see you guys ah you guys
are just so amazing and it's just so
much fun getting a chance to actually
see you so I'll see you soon bye